هي منشأة تخزين عالية التقنية وآمنة للغاية ،
ولدينا قبو نبيذ وخزانة تلقائية
أو استعادة Ferraris Lamborghinis
Porsches لدينا قبوًا فنيًا حيث نقوم
بتخزين أعمال فنية رائعة عالية القيمة
ولدينا قبو ودائع آمن
لدي العديد من السيارات مثل Ferraris
High  - إنهاء السيارات الغريبة ،
هذه السيارات باهظة الثمن إلى حد ما ، لذا
فأنت تريد التأكد من أنه عند
أخذها للخارج للقيادة ، فإنها لا تزال
سليمة ، حيث يعد robohelp مكانًا رائعًا للاحتفاظ
بها لأنك تعلم
أنها ستكون آمنة بمجرد  ضعها بعيدًا ،
إنها تقريبًا مثل صندوق ودائع
آمن لسيارتك ، لم يكن لدي مساحة كبيرة
في منزلي ، لذلك اعتقدت أنه من
المهم أن يكون لدي مرفق تخزين منفصل
للنبيذ
خارج منزلي لأن جزءًا منه
هو استثمار  Barbara ممتع
ولا تريد أن تشرب كل
زجاجات استثماراتك تتراوح من 50 دولارًا
للزجاجة التي أعتقد أنها من
أفضل الزجاجات هنا وبعض من
أغلى زجاجاتي يصل سعرها إلى 5000 دولار
للزجاجة التي أمتلكها  بطاقة ey ثم لدي
بصمة إصبعي التي هي أنت لذا أمشي فيها ،
وأمسح بطاقتي الرئيسية وأضع إصبعي على
الباب ويفتح الباب لي ، لذا فهي عملية سهلة حقًا
قد ينظر إليها شخص ما
ويقول إنها باهظة الثمن وأعتقد أن هذا
القبو هنا  حوالي 500 دولار شهريًا ، أعتقد أنه
عندما تضع في الحسبان تكلفة
الكهرباء
لمولد احتياطي للرطوبة المناسبة وما
أعتقد أنه رخيص جدًا ،
فهو ذو تقنية عالية جدًا من حيث أن منطقتنا الآلية التي يتم
تشغيلها آليًا بالكامل هي المكان الذي
نخزن فيه العناصر 35  يصل ارتفاعها إلى 60 قدمًا فوق مستوى سطح البحر ،
لذلك لا يوجد وصول بشري ، فهي
خالية من الغبار تقريبًا ، كما أن لدينا
مجموعات السيارات التي قد تساوي ملايين
المجموعات الفنية التي ستكون
بأرقام عالية جدًا من ستة
أرقام وحتى الأشياء التي قد لا تكون
باهظة الثمن ولكن  إنها لا تقدر بثمن بالنسبة
للشخص الذي يمتلكها ، فأنا أحتفظ ببعض
الأثاث هنا وأعمل غريبًا ، فهذا
يجعلني أنام بشكل أفضل في الليل مع العلم
أنهم لن
يتضرروا ولن تتم سرقتهم  هي
لوحات أخطط لتقديمها
لأولادي لذا أريد أن أبقيهم في
حالة جيدة